[Música]
el 29 de noviembre de 1947 Naciones
Unidas creó el plan de partición de
Palestina y seis meses después se llevó
a cabo la creación del estado de Israel
para el Éxodo judío con esto Se generó
un conflicto de daños que 75 años
después no alcanza su objetivo ni Paz ni
estado para los palestinos que poblaban
esas tierras saludamos Alexander en
Montero experto en relaciones
internacionales también inteligencia
estratégica diplomacia de seguridad y
defensa internacional y medio oriente
gracias Alexander por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de martes en directo América
de France 24 esta resolución se creó
luego el holocausto judío durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial para ubicar a
estos judíos sobrevivientes no Y la
asamblea entonces de la ONU de luz verde
hace hoy 75 años atrás a esta resolución
181 que complementaba y también
contemplaba la creación de dos estados
uno para Israel y otro para Palestina y
la Ciudad de Jerusalén que iba a quedar
bajo un control internacional no
gestando uno de los conflictos son más
largos del 20 Siglo 21 estuvo mal
implementado este acuerdo
un saludo a todos los los televidentes
en efectos y estuvo mal implementado hay
que tener en cuenta que esta resolución
se hace sin ninguna lógica territorial
la posición colombiana en ese momento
fue bastante diciembre Colombia Se
abstuvo a votar la resolución porque
para Colombia le parecía caprichoso la
distribución porcentual que estaba
planteando las Naciones Unidas la
delegación colombiana afirmaba que muy
seguramente no se iba a tomar una buena
resolución y que se iba a incrementar el
caos en lugar de buscar una salida
pacífica y el objetivo que se buscaba
que era la estabilidad de los dos
pueblos sin duda alguna la resolución se
hizo añicos al día siguiente con la
Primera Guerra Mundial y la ampliación
territorial de Israel pasando de un 56%
un 78%. ya no encontraría entre otras
cosas de la misma
de la carta San Francisco que prohibía
la adquisición de territorios por la
fuerza no obstante lo que queda de
trasfondo Más allá de estos detalles es
un un interés ya vemoslo así de un
proyecto colonial que nace de la mano
con los británicos y que tenía más que
elementos culturales o religiosos tenía
un trasfondo netamente geopolítico
también
digamos viendo 75 años después de esto y
cómo están las cosas en la actualidad no
llena de violencia en esa en esa región
Hay posibilidad real para dos estados en
un futuro digamos o mediano
Mira yo creo que aquí hay un un consenso
en cuanto intenciones tanto la comunidad
internacional
y cuando hablo comunidad internacional
no solamente hablo el Cuarteto que fue
el facilitador de la negociaciones de
los 90s sino Incluso el mundo musulmán
Incluso el medio oriente evidentemente
la misma Palestina tienen como primera
opción como primer salida la solución de
los dos estados casualmente es Israel el
que no el camina de la mano con esto
desde hace cuando menos 25 años después
que hizo Volar por los aires Los
acuerdos de oslo El radicalismo israelí
ha habido una seguidilla de gobiernos
que no son para nada amigos de los dos
estados y abiertamente lo que no es la
solución hoy mismo el gobierno realiza
compone de movimientos de
posiciones extremas religiosas ni
siquiera me atrevería a llamarlos de
extrema derecha porque la derecha es
otra cosa de posiciones fundamentalistas
religiosas que hablan básicamente de la
eliminación de cualquier proyecto
palestino esto llevaba una práctica se
tienen que cruzar con los miles de
asentamientos que Israel construye
dentro de Palestina hay que tener claro
que Israel no construya asentamientos
dentro de Israel dentro de su territorio
sino los construye dentro de Palestina
haciendo inviable en la práctica
cualquier posibilidad de de un estado
palestino con continuidad territorial
adicionalmente hay que recordar que
Israel hace varios años la nese del
parlamento israelí
autodefinido al Estado Israel como un
estado netamente judío Cuál es bastante
sorprendente a estas alturas del sistema
internacional y que negaría también la
posibilidad incluso de un estado
binacional habladas de algo muy
importante el riesgo de una elección
casi de todas y Jordania a uno mayor no
con este gobierno de extrema derecha y
también
religioso como lo estaba definiendo
Alexander y también otra pregunta que me
llama la atención es porque la comunidad
internacional realmente no hace algo al
respecto no para para la creación de dos
estados o por menos para que se respete
la soberanía Palestina
pero el actual gobierno de Israel prende
alarmas en todo lado entre otras cosas
en Estados Unidos que es su Aliado
principal había la posibilidad o ahí la
posibilidad incluso que el poder real lo
ejerzan estos partidos de extremismo
religioso en Israel que controlen
ministerios clave con el Ministerio de
defensa como el Ministerio de seguridad
interior o incluso que se les asignen
carteras nuevas como los ministerios de
seguridad nacional por ejemplo a líderes
de estos partidos de extremismo
religioso esto ha provocado que en el
mismo Estados Unidos como le decía le
envía mensajes claros a Israel le diga
que esto es una equivocación incluso su
su
varios ex generales del ejército israelí
han planteado lo que esto es una
equivocación que no trae ningún tipo de
beneficios ni siquiera para mí mismo
Israel pero parece que netanyahu va a
ser caso omiso en toda esta advertencias
y se van a enfrascar en una empresa
tremendamente peligrosa de colonización
en gran escala de cisjordania y de
Jerusalén este ahora bien porque la
comunidad internacional no hace nada Yo
creo que es una pregunta muy compleja
tiene muchas respuestas pero muy
rápidamente La primera y la más fuerte
porque evidentemente el sionismo ha sido
muy hábil ha secuestrado el concepto de
judaísmo y de tal manera que hoy acusa
de antisemita a cualquiera que critique
al Estado de Israel esto sin duda alguna
pesa mucho sobre todo en Europa porque
estamos como Alemania tienen una deuda
permanente en ese sentido y respaldarían
a Israel en consecuencia de una manera y
restricta hay una por otro lado hay una
gran influencia el lobo israelí sobre
todo en la política británica en la
política estadounidense la política
francesa que impiden también que esos
estados tomen decisión de fondo en
relación con con Palestina y tal vez el
último factor Y es que lo palestino
israelí pasó un segundo Incluso un
tercer plano en el medio oriente otros
temas como la guerra civil en Siria como
las tensiones entre Irán y Saudita han
hecho que lo palestinos sea hoy más
invisible que que nunca y esto sin duda
alguna es aprovechado por Israel para
continuar la colonización día a día